Cử dụng sợi bình gử dụng khá rí trên nhau của quạc máy là mắt giữa đợt nắng kỳ lục ở trô ông.
Khi hệ thống xưa thị lý đờ thông báo phân phối khoảng 2,5 gình sản phẩm,
quốc quạc và điều hoa tới hơn 1 gình xấu trăm cửa hàng trên khám đứa pháp,
hàng trong người dân đã đứng trước các xưa tị này ở pary từ năm dở sáng ngày hai tháng bẩy để mua hàng.
Nhong người số sát, khiến kẹn sát phải cả thịp dài tạm đồng.
Tình chạc này dễn ra khí pháp và nhiều nước trô ông đang trẻ qua một trong những dựng nắng khác nhét nhất nhiều năm.
Nhất độ tại một số khu vực vượt của một mì rộ xe khiến hàng gỳ lục đường, nhiều bẩy viện qua tài và hạ tần rao thông biển hơn.
Dưới trước ít tế pháp cho biết, đợt nắng đặc khiến khoảng 1 in ba trong người từ vòng,
và lẫn là người từ 6.5 tội trở lên,
cơ quan khi tượng nước này cảnh báo một dựng nắng mởi có thể tiếp tục sát hiện vào tần tới.